para el propietario de una opción de
compra con un precio de ejercicio de 50
dólares y una cierta expiración estamos
seguros del valor de la posición si el
precio de las acciones es menor que 50
nosotros no ejercemos la opción pues
podemos comprar las acciones más baratas
de lo que la opción no se está dando
pero si las acciones van por arriba de
los 50 dólares nosotros ejercemos
nuestra opción para comprar las acciones
en 50 y si pensamos que estudiar el 60
que el precio de subyacente estuvieran
60 dólares en la fecha de expiración
nosotros ejercerían de esta opción para
comprarla en 50 y venderlas en 60 y así
ganaríamos 10 dólares esencialmente
obtendríamos una ganancia si las
acciones van por arriba de 50 dólares
pensando acerca del valor actual de la
posición si queremos un factor de cuánto
pagamos por la opción nosotros
simplemente deslizamos esto hacia abajo
por 10 dólares hace del tenedor y luce
así nosotros prácticamente si no
ejercemos la opción perdemos el monto de
dinero pagado por está rompiendo con
esto a partir de los 60 dólares y justo
ahí es cuando comenzamos a hacer dinero
pues son 60 dólares y él va
nuestra opción son 10 dólares que
pagamos por el contrato y bien esta es
la perspectiva o punto de vista del
tenedor de la opción de compra del
tenedor de la opción de compra es el
dueño de la opción y si tú estuvieras
del lado del escrito de la opción de
compra del lado de la persona que vende
el derecho de compra de las acciones
está persona estará aquí si el tenedor
tiene el derecho de comprar pues
razonablemente alguien debe estar
vendiendo estos derechos alguien debe
estar acordando que si tú dijese hey yo
quiero el derecho esencialmente te lo
venda a un cierto precio entonces si
eres el emisor de las opciones y por
aquí pondremos al tenedor en verde pero
bueno como emisor eres el chapuzón en el
partido de nuestra opción eres la
persona que accedió mantener la opción
entonces si la opción nunca se ejerce el
emisor no pierde dinero se queda con lo
que gano de la opción y cuando ésta es
ejercida comienza a perder dinero porque
si el emisor no es el propietario de las
acciones y escucha que la acción está en
60 dólares
tenedor puede ejercer su opción para
comprarla en 50 así el emisor después
tendrá que ir y comprar las acciones en
el mercado a 60 dólares para venderlas
en 50 por lo que perderán 10 dólares y
los pagos de los emisores lucirán algo
así y una vez más es una imagen espejo
de los pagos del tenedor al pensar en
pérdidas y ganancias del emisor si la
opción nunca se ejerce el espectador
sólo obtendrá los 10 dólares que se
pagaron por el contrato los 10 dólares
que costó el contrato pues vendido en el
derecho pero si la opción es ejercida
comienzan a perder dinero otra vez desde
el punto de los 60 dólares y cualquier
cantidad por debajo de 60 comienzan a
perder más y más dinero de nueva cuenta
es la imagen espejo el uno del otro y si
estás en estas dos líneas eran
interceptadas pues hay una parte
intercambiando el dinero entre éstas por
algún lado una parte hace diez dólares y
el otro pierde diez dólares
o viceversa